[Applause]
[Music]
i want the world
to see the process
[Music]
i want everyone to see the highs and the
lows and the hard work and the the never
giving up
because a lot of people say like oh i
want to be a singer i want to be
famous they have no idea what it takes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at how big these are
a rainbow top
there's no book
on
how to make a pop group 101 how to be a
star 101. there's none of that so for my
career it was always just kind of figure
it out i can't believe this guys
now we know we know what works we know
what doesn't we know what to do we know
how to get there we know what it takes
we know the difference in a kid that
hasn't a kid that just doesn't and i
wish i lived here i want kids in this
pop group that have something special
about them
i don't want a normal kid
so what do you guys think of the house
[Applause]
it's gonna be
a lot of fun but a lot of hard work you
think you're gonna be able to handle my
mom
i thought the same thing when i was nine
and look at you now look where i am now
so it may work
we are going to make you guys the next
phenomenon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's my happy dance
i want to make you
my pop group that officially has a name
now so the name of the pop group is
xomg pop
the name is so important i liked x
oh like just like exo like hug and kiss
i also like omg just because it's cute
we say it a lot
and when you go like please welcome xomg
it sounds
freaking awesome
okay so whenever we go to an amusement
park which i'm sure i'll be taking you
one day
i always go everybody follow me and this
is what we do
[Music]
[Music]
these are the luckiest kids yeah
we have a long road ahead of us
i know it's going to get tough because
i've been down this road
we have a lot of work to do but it's
important to me that tonight's fun
guys there's lots of stuff here if you
want to go around and just like check it
all out like it's all for you yeah
[Music]
we all have big dreams for our kids but
this is something like i didn't ever
even dare to dream like big enough for
my kid you dreamed it for all these kids
and like we're just grateful because
and without your vision none of us would
be here either if you look at any
celebrity they started young and i'm
like that's what we got to do a lot of
people might not know this but my mom
was actually a dance teacher she has
owned three dance studios and she opened
up her first one when she was only 17.
there's not any other
child phenomenons right now my mom has
choreographed hundreds of dances been to
millions of dance competitions if anyone
knows how to put together a girl group
pop phenomenon it's my mom it's time
like it is time for some kids to take it
over
[Music]
let's take a look
[Music]